have you seen already Jojo I have I
watched the JoJo ones up to uh the last
one on Netflix yeah I guess part six
like Florida I saw some of the Florida
prison one
um I haven't finished it yet though yeah
um but yeah no I've I do you [__] with
it yeah no I love JoJo it's weird as
[__]
um I have a bad tank according to Connor
I tell people not to watch part one yeah
well I'll tell people like it's a little
I mean it's very different
it's like a different show that they
made for some reason obviously there's
backbone there you know like the
podenada food and you know the speed
wagon or not part of the speed Wagner
and and you know everyone else like the
whole family lineage is established
there but like other than that it's like
a different anime yeah yeah but it's
nice you kind of you get you get like
rewarded for watching and I feel like
you can appreciate the show more yeah
off and wildly changing it up but then
also having little crumbs that kind of
like rewards yeah especially when you
get to like the later later pass like
seven and eight where it's where
actually they start to call back to
stuff in part one it's like oh okay
you know and they're doing all this
weird [__] [__] that makes no sense
already because they don't explain
stands ever yeah because like why would
they because you've watched part three
yeah right and then they're like oh and
then we're gonna get the we're gonna get
the Stan to the Speedwagon Foundation
it's like what does any of these words
mean yeah no you have to watch that's
what I mean though like you just
establish him as a character and like
but then after that it's like it just
drops you into this world we're like oh
the fighting sequence has changed
completely like yeah that's cool I guess
yeah I mean I really like it because I
it's like even though part one is my
least favorite part it's kind of like a
time stamp of the era that it was made
in right you know it's very reminiscent
of the OG 80s action movie yes
everyone's like overly buff and
everyone's like a giga chat I love it
get less gigger chat over yeah yeah yeah
I mean I like it though I like that it's
they're all evolving yeah for sure which
one's your favorite part ooh
my favorite is Cujo so I probably like
is is that part six well oh no sorry
Cujo oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so like Kira and all of
that that's possible
yeah is in part four as well yeah yeah
right with the pompadour yeah yeah yeah
oh no no no not josuke no no no with the
hataro yeah he's in part three four and
six and six yeah yeah you just like him
I just like him he's my favorite he's
the most popular yeah okay that makes
sense but I think in Japan Dio is the
most popular character really yeah well
he he's probably like the biggest
recurring character outside of it he
turns into everything Japan loves the
bad boys man yeah they do they do that's
exactly that's surprising
because he's like super charismatic and
crazy
he's like psychotic Japan loves
psychotic characters like why would you
root for the bad guy that makes no sense
what no because he's epic I love him
what the
[__] stage presence you know and the
the Japanese voices are so goddamn good
yeah uh it's so [__] good yeah I
think it's just just because he is you
know Japan being like a very let's say a
very quiet Society they love someone
who's like more eccentric shows himself
we do like this [__] annoying uh like
you know my first experience with JoJo
walls it was the [__] Steam Sale
edits where they would have you seen
these when they oh yeah yeah like uh
they would have these meme edits where
it was like a steam when back when steam
Steam Sale was a big meme yeah obviously
it's always everything's Dirt Cheap yeah
and they would do like the final fight
in part three yeah versus jotro and it
would just be like because he screams
muda so many times yeah just like
throwing More Steam Sale memes like
another sale another sale that's the
first time you ever saw JoJo who's the
first time
as a meme and I just didn't understand
that's how Connor discovers most things
yeah yeah because it was like I was like
what the [__] is this and then there's
this dude screaming and there's and
jotra was like the wallet and Dio is
like the money like the guy take the
steams yeah I have no idea how I got
into JoJo yeah how did you I don't know
I literally have no because it's like
it's like one of those things where it's
so popular and it has like an annoying
fan base yeah so then like kind of like
one piece as a matter of fact I would
say is that is that how is that how you
get into anime are you just like you get
I get bullied into it you get bullied
yeah no no no I don't think JoJo was
like you have to watch this like
um but it just I don't know well yeah
because JoJo fans have like the
reputation of being the annoying fan
base oh yeah never being able to shut up
about the show yeah which is totally
true by the way I feel like there's
every anime fan base one piece love to
pretend they're not like that but one
piece fancy oh my God one piece is way I
promise you like if someone watched Jojo
and is currently watching One Piece yeah
one piece was way worse with respect to
like how much they were like bro you you
have to watch One Piece and it's such a
it's like a Biblical text like
it's too many episodes so you're like I
don't have that kind of time we're
talking I'm on the New Testament yeah
yeah yeah it's like I don't have that
kind of time commitment like I can't do
this and then and then you get into it
and you're like oh my God it's so good
yeah I have people now in my fan base
that just like don't know me for
politics but just like listen to me talk
about one piece because like there's I
have thousands of fan channels on
YouTube right like I don't have any IP
or anything so I'm like whatever you
know let it ride who cares yeah yeah
there's this one fan channel that made
an edit
um about how I like used to talk [__]
about one piece and I started watching
it and those videos independently this
Channel's got like 10K subs or something
like nothing crazy yeah that video had
like 100 000 views on its own and now
he's just like detailing and documenting
every single episode and every single
Arc that I like summarize basically as
I'm watching it and like there is a fan
base for that oh yeah you have one piece
yeah everything which is a very
political anime Conor it's okay it is a
very political watch he told me one
piece is very political yes what aspect
oh my God yes I love this this is gonna
piss off everybody but I'm so right
about this even though like no okay like
okay first of all every single Arc well
other than like the first couple of arcs
every single Arc quite literally details
like leftist politics which I think Oda
is Oda is 100 Oda is 100 left is first
of all
he has Jake he has a Che Guevara photo
in a studio 100 look it up establish
fact I have assets
what else what else okay so that's
number one number two which Arc are you
on I don't want to like spoil anything
he's uh yeah
uh water seven yeah okay
um so Thriller bark kind of sucks I'm
sorry to hear that that's uh the ending
is great but like everything else is
kind of mid but it's fine because what
comes after is
that means you watch like you watch
Alabaster right yeah which is definitely
political but like not as aggressively
but it's about like resource deprivation
things like that but then Sky Pia which
again may be a little bit too long as an
arc is quite literally about like you
know indigenous uh populations being
removed from their land and like
violently trying to to to uh you know
find autonomy and emancipation through
you know through violent means directly
against like an enemy that is much more
powerful to them right that is like you
know that's like a land back movement
which is inherently very political very
leftist
um I've watched a different I read it
yeah I know I I was trying to describe
this to him he's like what are you
talking about it's about like man I saw
funny gum men yeah yeah no one piece
about having fun with your friends and
being free yeah exactly I mean first of
all Luffy is a terrorist
I mean he's fighting I I hate that
you're kind of right yes I [__] hate
that you're kind of right yeah he is a
freedom fighter in the in the most like
honorable sense of the word he is quite
literally fighting against an
unjustifiable corrupt military apparatus
that is like holding the entire world
hostage the world government and the
Navy he's literally killing cops like
like he's killing sea cops and
[__] are like no no that's not
politics what do you mean that's just
like gum man having fun I mean the thing
is like I remember you saying this
yesterday when we were having dinner and
I was just like
um I I mean I I think with one piece
just because of the art style and just
the way things are ha funny rubber man
of course you know you can you can take
it at that level and it's still very
very interesting stories but if you
break down some of the stuff that
happens half of it is uh Luffy going up
against a corrupt government or corrupt
yeah I mean like you need to start an
anime analysis Channel I would
legitimately watch like a 15-minute
breakdown
Hogwarts Legacy
yeah
it's I'm not even well there's like
there's a there's trans representation
in that too but we're not gonna get into
that right now yeah but
um as far as like uh Oda goes I mean
here there is the uh I think like
dragons does I mean I don't want to like
spoil anything but
um Oda Oda has talked about how dragon's
design was inspired in part by a
revolutionaries like Fidel Castro yeah
he has a Che Guevara photo in his in his
uh office I believe okay I don't know
this part yet I'm not at that part yet
so I can't speak on this but I think
dragon's ship is literally the same name
as Fidel Castro's ship okay but here's
the thing here's the thing
um I think sometimes you know especially
when you see this a lot in Japanese
manga sometimes authors will put [__] in
there just because it looks cool oh yeah
right sometimes it's there there it's
it's like you know the curtain is blue
kind of like argument sometimes you look
at something and it's a reference to uh
some Western Media or Western history
and a lot of the times it's just
Japanese people find Western things that
a fun question no no it's too many it's
too many coincidences listen listen
listen the bolivaran revolution in Cuba
was conducted with a yacht that will use
to transport 82 fighters of the Cuban
Revolution from Mexico to Cuba okay okay
the yacht's name is Grandma
without a d Grandma which is the exact
same uh is the exact same name as a
dragon's ship
like that's come on that's not like that
he didn't just see that and was like
because like you have to be like really
invested you have to be a weeb for
communism to like put that in there I
think he's just a weed for history
honestly like yeah with with the amount
of lore that one piece has the like one
piece has some of the most intricate
World building in your opinion any piece
of media oh absolutely like it's it's
obviously one of the most intricate
worlds in anime manga but I think it's
up there with like some of the best
worlds I've been in any like book movie
or TV series yeah right and you you
can't do that without doing a [__] ton
of history on just the history of the
world yeah yes being for sure being
inspired by a lot of events that might
have taken place uh in real world
history I'm just saying it points too
many fingers in One Direction oh here's
a here's a photo from oda's Office Space
where he has like uh his airsoft guns
and then like a photo of chegevara right
now I'm just saying dude he's got
prepared
anyway so that's that's definitely
that's definitely a spicy one because
like a lot of people watch anime and
like don't really think about like who's
making it or how they're making it or
what they intend to do with their art so
like I know a lot of people will watch
that and still be like yo [__] that
that's all I think a lot of people view
anime as being almost uh non-political
yeah an escape from yeah